[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
55 q and a segment with
animals yep that's right
here we are yes all right well said
maddie
my goodness all right um
all right the first one i forgot about
this uh the first one
from last time we're going to start with
four questions from last time move
to the discord question and then in the
questions from the last hour
someone asked for me to read ode to spot
by data the android from star trek
and i have forgotten about it but i have
it pulled up here
and i will find it and we will do it
if i can figure out how to use my
computer
that didn't work at all okay
here we go okay so this is a poem
supposedly written by lieutenant
commander data ode to spot
felis catus is your taxonomic
nomenclature an endothermic quadruped
carnivorous by nature your visual
olfactory and auditory senses contribute
to your hunting skills and natural
defenses
i find myself intrigued by your subvocal
oscillations a singular development of
cat communications
that obviates your basic hedonistic
predilection for a rhythmic stroking of
your fur to demonstrate affection
a tale is quite essential for your
acrobatic talents you would not be so
agile if you lacked its counterbalance
and when not being utilized to aid in
locomotion it often serves to illustrate
the state of your emotion
oh spot the complex levels of behavior
you display
connote a fairly well-developed
cognitive array and though you are not
sentient spot and do not comprehend
i nonetheless consider you a true and
valued friend
that's beautiful that's wonderful why is
it an ode to spot his cat's name is
spock his cat's name is sponsored
his cat's name is spot yeah yeah yeah it
does
raise a certain question though because
obviously that was
not written by an android that was
written by a person yes one of themself
in the mindset of an android there's all
sorts of discussion online as you will
no doubt not be surprised to find as to
who
exactly actually wrote that and put
those words into data's mouth yes
yes that's a good question but
apparently data
rather loved his spot he had a cat i
don't recall this
it's been forever yeah
all right uh next question kindly share
your sources and articles that support
the lab leak hypothesis it needs more
attention love you both
um yes i would say uh best thing to do
is actually to follow yuri degen
elena chan and rosana
segreto on twitter and you will have the
ongoing
development of the vanguard of
investigation into what the
origin of covet 19 and sars kobe 2 might
be
and your conversation uh with yuri dagan
from april or may uh is up on this
channel as well
and you discuss some of the sources as
well oh well yeah it's certainly a good
place that you can get a grounding you
can also look at yuri degen's
uh initial medium post that lays the
whole thing out so well
it might be time to revisit actually
yeah because
we are a great deal down the road from
this
and we have learned a lot and i would
say
it is interesting the lab leak
hypothesis has not been falsified
it has grown stronger so might be worth
going back there at some point good
next question what are your thoughts on
teenage antidepressant use
the standard practice of school security
to search oh second
what are your thoughts on a teenage
antidepressant use and
b the standard practice of schools
security to search student belongings
um boy when i read that the first time i
only saw the first half teenage
antidepressant use
um i think with almost all of these
mood affecting drugs there are
some cases in which they are the right
move
and almost all of the cases in which
they are used
they they should be a last resort rather
than a first resort
which is too often how they're being
used and
i think the idea of
putting such drugs into a developing
human's brain
when all is chaos um when you know
there's a lot of restructuring going on
and um reframing of neuronal connections
um there are potentially going to be
long-term consequences that we have
no idea of at this point yeah it's
effectively inevitable
because the mind is learning how to
think and to feel and to balance
things and to the extent that you are
interfering with
the processing you are creating
potentially a lifelong
dependence it is also the case
that these things have been massively
affected by
what is being called the replication
crisis and there
is a huge bias in favor of seeing
effectiveness of these things that may
not be what we think it is or may be
ephemeral
so to the extent that almost any change
of scene
can take a person who is mired in
depression and caused them
to drop out of it because things are
somehow different and feel different and
all of that
but it's not a long-term solution
we we may have a very wrong idea even
where they work about why they work and
what's taking place and so yeah it's uh
very very scary that we would have leapt
to this
and largely sidelined other
modes in which a you know my mind that
is not settled and doesn't feel right
could learn
those skills and have them for the rest
of the person's life
yeah and in some cases your mind isn't
settled and things don't feel right
because something is wrong in your world
and dampening that ability to respond to
that uh is
actually more dangerous than feeling the
upset in the first place
yeah that's all true i would say the
caveat here and the problem that it is
the reason it is so hard to have this
discussion
is that obviously people harm themselves
and it will not be the case even if all
it is
is a change of scene even if it just
causes
the mind to feel different it will
certainly be saving
some lives that's not to say that in the
end it doesn't result in more people
harming themselves yeah
but you know one does not want to take a
position and say
these things are bad when you know there
are
likely to be people walking around who
wouldn't otherwise be because it got in
the road of some
you know cascading mental phenomenon at
some point where the person needed it to
get in the road
um but but god damn it we can do better
yeah
this is not uh we don't know nearly
enough about the brain to interfere with
it that way and the model
on which these things were predicated is
known to be false
right this idea of chemical imbalances
that's
possible that they exist in some cases
it is very unlikely to be
involved in uh the majority of cases
which doesn't mean that you can't you
know if if if
if we really are experiencing an
epidemic of chemical imbalances in the
brain it wasn't true 500 years ago
yeah it wasn't true 2000 years ago it
wasn't even true 200 years ago therefore
this is something that we are doing to
ourselves and
rather than treating the symptom of
something that is resulting from
something we are doing to ourselves we
should figure out what it is in the
modern environment that is causing this
absolutely uh the second part of this
which um is what are your thoughts on
the standard practice of school security
to search student belongings
this is a more complicated question and
i actually don't know it to be the case
it's not the case
well our one of our children has never
even been to the school that he attends
since he started this year and
it's been all virtual but i don't know
it to be the case at
his school and it's not the case of the
other guy's school so
um yeah there are certainly situations
in which um
it is unfortunately probably called for
and um
that's a that's a tough question yeah
yeah it is
do you have thoughts on government
brown's government
that's not a word government browns
governor brown's new two-week freeze
and whether or not it'll only be two
weeks i am well i emailed you on behalf
of an oregonian seeking help and
creating restrictions and oversight for
the governor's emergency powers
yeah so we are what on day three day
four now i guess of the freeze
um
i don't know i don't know if it'll only
be two weeks yeah and um
you know it's not it's not the lockdown
that we had in march
april um because all the retail stores
are open
they're just at 75 capacity or something
like that
um and i think it's
it's a real shame one of the ways that
it's being done well we talked last week
about one of the ways it's being done
being a real shame which is that they've
closed down the gardens for instance you
know
portland has this beautiful world-famous
japanese garden
to which i've been going with some
regularity and it's closed it's a garden
it's outside
i'm not going to be walking my dog no no
no way
um no but you know i'll hold jokes aside
you know the garden shouldn't be closed
probably the zoo shouldn't be closed but
also
a lot of restaurants here you know
portland has an extraordinary food scene
and a lot of the restaurants had really
been ramping up their
outdoor seating as the weather changed
like they've got
not just um canopies
but um heaters you know where there's
still a lot of airflow
um it's but it's definitely outside um
but it's but it's warm and a lot of
these places had just
it appears to me had just gotten it
ready
and now they're being told that you can
only do takeout and delivery
and you know so now this stuff is
sitting outside
not being used um potentially you know
at risk of being damaged
and i don't see why a lockdown
that is due that is supposed to be doing
what this one is supposed to be doing
should be preventing restaurants from
serving people outside
yeah and we have been consistent about
this from the beginning we should be
borrowing from the places where the
virus
is not successful at transmitting in
order that we can afford
to institute precautions that people
will find
somewhat onerous where they actually
work and this sort of
you know it's just this
sense of like the purpose of governance
is to do something rather than to be
effective you
want to be effective at the minimal
possible intensity and this does not
it does not feel surgical and
i'm increasingly worried that bad
testing um and bad models
for what the virus is are resulting in
very
blunt interventions that um blunt and
like aimed wrong
yeah like you know when they do hit
their target they don't have much of an
effect and often too often they're aimed
at the wrong target yeah and i guess i
would like to start the discussion
not about sars kovi ii and kovid 19 but
about next time
because in some sense i feel like well
we bought this one
we know how bad that is
and next time you want to get
on the ball right away you want to be on
the same page about what we're trying to
accomplish
so that the interventions are surgical
they might need to be intense and
short-lived and we don't want half the
population
freaking out that that's tyranny having
arrived
that means we have to protect people
from these sorts of things being used in
a tyrannical fashion so anyway let's
have that conversation
now yeah so that next time we can
actually
be epidemiologically effective and
stop this in its tracks before we find
ourselves in this
you know quagmire yeah okay the question
from discord this week
actually from last week because i missed
it last week was
is you have discussed the fact that
young people are not being given the
tools they need to compete in a
meritocracy
what are these tools and how do they
function um
well you want to go you want me to go
you go first
um i would say
that the the key
tools involve experience
in systems boy there's going to be no
way to answer this because i think the
answer is
painfully obvious and so something about
the word tools must be throwing
people to to ask that question but in
some sense
you know we spend a lot of time talking
about the difference
between knowing how something is done
and knowing how to do it right you
probably know
enough physics to do parkour you
probably don't do any parkour
and you couldn't just go out into your
city center and say well okay i know how
how it works and just start you know
bouncing off things and jumping over
others and all of that
point is how do you get there you get
there
through some pathway in which each
jump is small enough from the last one
that you pick up the skill so that
eventually when we tune in on your doing
parkour
you're able to do amazing things that
cause us to boggle right
so everything is like this right you
want to do science
well you're going to need to go through
a lot of iterations
of formulating a hypothesis figuring out
what the predictions are
testing them figuring out how it comes
back as a muddle
and how you're going to do it better
next time and so
go on so you know i guess what i would
say is the key tool
is a prototyping mentality whether
that's metaphorical prototyping where
you're talking conceptually
or it's literal prototyping where you
build something that proves that the
thing that you want to invent is
actually possible
and then you work your way there in
steps
and iterative practice and play which
can be about prototyping but isn't
inherently i'm reminded of so our
youngest on toby and i've been playing a
lot of pool lately
and um we have we have generated three
categories of shots
um i see my shot and i have the skill to
do it whether or not i make the shot or
not
i see the shot i know what i want to do
but i don't think i have the skill to
accomplish it
and i actually don't even know how to do
this
i i can i think that that's possible but
i don't even know how to get there i
don't even know
like i both lack the theoretical insight
and the skill
and that's pretty rare like much more
often both of us find ourselves in this
position of
i know what i want the balls to do but
i'm not sure i'm not sure
how much english this that and the other
right to do to
to get there um and just like creating
those kinds of categories for any given
thing that you're doing be it playing
pool
or building a table or bicycle riding or
you know robotics or you know any of
these things and ending up with
categories of okay where
when when i didn't accomplish the thing
did i not accomplish it because i just
failed to try well just no don't ever do
that
but did i was i too confident of what i
knew and i actually was missing the full
landscape of possibility of outcomes
um was i missing some key tool maybe um
was i missing some key insight
and you know do i tend to make errors of
the same type
of category such that oh actually i just
need more stuff like i just need more
more tools usually that's not the case
but for some people that will be
more often it's i need more experience
of the system sufficient that i actually
have a more complete model
of what kinds of things it throws at me
so that i have encountered this sort of
problem
more regularly and have a sense of what
to do to
unravel it yeah and if i can um
add something that i think this implies
a huge fraction of what we actually know
when we are
expert at something in some meaningful
way like actually
capable of advancing a field or whatever
it comes from a huge store of knowledge
that is not describable right
you become expert in something and there
is the part that you can convey
with words and then there's a lot of
stuff that is stored in some other way
and it sometimes
gets metaphorically described as muscle
memory or whatever it is or
lab hands or any of these things but
you're distinct from jazz hands am i
right totally distinct in fact if you
do that in the laboratory breaks well
there's demerits galore and then you
could also knock over a
erlenmeyer flask or i don't know what
but um but it's not good
yeah um yeah so sorry
it's all right so anyway the point is
look
there's a way school is so broken
right what we teach you is largely
how to compel the person who gave the
assignment
that you did the reading or something
right
it's not about show
and i increasingly i think look somebody
who can show
it's not important that they can
describe it it's great if they can
describe it in addition to showing
how to do it but well no i would say i
would it depends on what the thing is
agreed right so if it's art um i think
you're right and often the statements
that accompany
artists works you know artist statements
right writing statements are actually
um a problem in their own way like i'd
rather not see those things
but um as you know
when i would teach animal behavior and
teach students you know from the very
beginning to like how do you how do you
even
come up with an idea in the first place
all the way through to the end so they
would have done a complete piece of
research from beginning to end the
communication in both written work with
ample review of the peer-reviewed
literature and in
a spoken talk about what they had what
they had found
was absolutely critical and that wasn't
just because i needed it to assess it
they needed to be able to translate what
they knew into words such
other people could understand it yeah
although there the skill
right the the entire field is there to
take things that are true of creatures
and discover them and
convey them into the body of shared
wisdom about them
so in some sense the point of the
exercise is
get something robust that can be
conveyed to the rest of us
um but even so
to the extent that somebody can
let's say um
reveal a pattern of animal behavior that
is previously unknown
a student who could take you into the
field and say
i want to show you something interesting
and they could show you something about
a creature that no one had ever
described before
they have accomplished something yes
they have a skill and if they can do it
twice then it was not a fluke
right so my point is that it's not the
complete skill set i was hoping they
would generate
oh right but um in fact seeing something
new that is heretofore undescribed by
science
is something most people will never do
including you know most people who are
publishing in scientific journals all
the time
absolutely and so all i'm saying is that
we don't
that show is its own thing
and that show arises
through a kind of iterated engagement
with something that allows you to
discover
things even if you never are consciously
aware of what you've discovered so you
have an intuition
about where to look how to you know
position yourself or whatever it is
and so yeah what are those tools those
tools are
deep engagement with systems that are
representative enough of the way
important systems work that you become
expert at
deducing what's true what's false how to
interact with the system in a way that's
productive
and so much of school is built
around say you know it's almost like it
trains you
to get by the you know the
filters of your teacher or your
professor rather than to know anything
about the world
because if you've succeeded if you've
convinced the prof that you're
you're on it and um you know your prof
might be a fool
yep it's a pretty good chance actually
pretty good chance
okay next question how can those lacking
in moral moral courage
learn to act in spite of fear especially
if the threat is real
simply saying just do it as i often hear
seems insufficient
as it avails no one to know what it is
to be done if it's not known
how to do it it's a great question
and it's uh it fits with um what is the
example people use
that the dog does not know
it's very difficult for the dog to learn
that the mailman is not a threat if the
dog barks at the mailman
every day and there is no attack on the
house right the dog never heard this the
dog may think
that it has fended off an attack each
and every day
and likewise the skittish cat doesn't
know
that it has failed to save its life by
hiding under the bed because it would
have to not do that
in order to discover that actually the
world does not come to an end when a
stranger walks by
yeah so how do you how do you break
those patterns with
the benefit of consciousness and
language
well i i think actually this one is a
good easily answered question
more easily answered than done but the
it actually it's the same answer as the
last one
these environments are a system
with an unwritten set of rules and
the if you say well
um well actually let me just report
i met somebody in that clubhouse
environment
and somebody i knew from twitter but
i've never met them in person
anyway we do you consider that you you
have now
i think so i don't know it's interesting
we need new terminology
um but anyway this is clubhouse which
you talked about last time being an
audio only real time conversation in
in spoken word yep and we were in a room
uh that was engaged in
uh an argument about racial dynamics
interracial dynamics and this person
said
of me that i said things that she would
have predicted would have caused
a catastrophe but then didn't and she
found that interesting
right in other word and i think i know
what she was seeing which was
that there's very often um
a way to work your way towards being
able to say something that you couldn't
go directly
and there's often a way to say things
with
you know slight alteration that makes
them more hearable than they would
be if you just tried to go at them
directly just because this is apropos
what you're saying are you saying that
she
saw this with regard to what you wrote
on twitter or what you said in clubhouse
said
said spoken right spoken word because it
is i mean i
i love to play with language to surprise
people
such that it's not what they thought it
was but it's
much easier to get people to jump on you
it's much easier for people to make an
error because they
because they think you've written
something that you haven't and it would
seem like it was easier in spoken word
because once it's done it's done like
sound passes and it does it's not it's
not permanent in the way but
because there's additional even more so
in person but
there's additional stuff around tone and
pauses and
you can just you can put more
intentionality into the way you say
something than you can just with letters
on a screen
yes and actually this is uh dovetailing
with a different conversation we were
having this week too you and i but
i would argue those two environments are
variations on a theme
but they have different assets and
liabilities associated with them
but in each case you're dealing with a
system in which one is
learning to be able to say things in
such a way that they are more easily
heard or that they don't cause a
conflagration
and the trick and the answer to this
question here is i think
you want to pick an environment in which
you can learn the skill that you're
trying
to get and partially the skill is you
know about
the boldness to try it and so you know
you're not going to try it all in one go
you're going to start with
something beyond what's comfortable
and partially the skill is how do i do
this and have the greatest chance
of surviving it you know living to fight
another day
and anyway i think the answer is
it's very learnable if you can find the
environment
where you can you know afford
the risks and in which the
lessons can be derived
through behavior you're comfortable with
yeah and those environments exist
um the next question i
i don't think the whole thing is here so
i'm just going to say it to suggest to
the person who wrote it that
that i need more of a question here um
can the
now it says can the study differentiate
domesticated animals from the parasites
and other hangers on
or how about rats or insects other pests
etc
um can the study
yes i just don't i don't know what this
is in reference to but this was a high
uh money value question so i wanted to
say i'm not ignoring it i just don't
know what it means
it's not a continuation of somebody i
looked no there's a couple other from
this person but it's not
it's not the same thing i see um
okay next question what are your
thoughts on the metoo movement it took
over our national consciousness around
the same time you two were railroaded
out of evergreen
yeah so evergreen blew up on may 23rd of
2017 and metoo
starts happening um and we went to the
first fire conference in october of 2017
and harvey weinstein was just
just beginning to make the news at that
point so it was fall of 2017.
um yeah i've i guess mostly it's been on
twitter
unfortunately but i had a lot to say at
the time it seemed like a potentially
important moment uh which could have
revealed
um to the vast majority of men out there
who were who are who are good men who
would never
behave in uh in
bad ways to women that that doesn't mean
that the vast majority of women at least
when we're younger
don't experience bad treatment at the
hands of a handful of men
so that's you know that's the that is
the truth of the matter
um it was then it became this activist
movement
or maybe it was from the start right i'm
not i don't actually know
exactly what the origins were and that
nuance that i just put in there was
never part of the conversation that i
heard
um you had you know people mocking the
hashtag
not all men um as if this were not true
and of course not only is it true that
not all men behave in these atrocious
and sort of could broke quid pro quo at
work uh for sexual favors ways
but the majority of men don't and um
that somehow was seen as
um anti-feminist anti-woman i said
i would say that and i have internalized
misogyny and now i've got internalized
reality i think
um you know that that said myself
like i think the vast majority of women
especially when we're younger
um have things happen that don't happen
to men
and uh we wish they wouldn't and it's
use it'd be useful for all men to
recognize that's actually something that
is going on but that was no way to
to bring that to awareness yeah
uh let me explain how this actually
works yeah go for it um
now the uh i think the thing is a
there's a huge amount of bad behavior
and that huge amount of bad behavior
and worse um is
uh you know grounds for a movement the
problem is that the nature of the
movement
is such that abuse of the
you know the hashtag is inevitable
and so what we saw was there was a lot
of energy because a lot of people have
experienced
bad treatment and then the thing got
carried away and suddenly
you know nuance was being uh stamped out
because it was
understood to be dangerous in and of
itself and so the thing became
a uh um you know
a mess of its own so
uh i would also say though that people
um the older you are i think the harder
it is to appreciate
how messed up the mating and dating
environment has become
for younger people and that part of what
is going on here
is that you have uh people at every
generation
who have stories to tell about bad
things that have happened to them but
that the way people are interacting
that young people are interacting are so
broken and predicated on such a faulty
model of human sexuality
that there is a huge amount of
dysfunction
and that huge amount of dysfunction is
sort of being shoehorned
into the same set of questions that
would be raised
by dysfunction that existed for older
generations and
the thing is a mess because we all
assume that we're talking about the same
thing
and i think we just aren't yep that's
right
uh this is a comment there was a news
article this week that described how the
italians got curious
and tested preserved blood samples from
a research project in september of 2019.
they found somewhere around ten percent
of the samples tested positive for
covert 19.
i i had not heard of this you're nodding
you i saw it yeah
have you you think it's real well
increasingly i'm having the sense
of okay now we have to sort between
where
are the tests broken and giving us some
very false signal
where are the tests accurate and telling
us something about the trajectory of the
virus is very different than we thought
but i did look at that result and i
thought whoa that's pretty interesting
and i wonder why we're not doing more of
this
i mean just in the same way that would
be easy of course
and of course there are going to be
samples that have been stored away in
all kinds of
uh different different places but um
it goes back to when kovid was first
happening and we started our live
streams we talked about
the instance of uh was it the teddy
roosevelt
the uh aircraft carrier that i think
that was the name of it although i'm not
sure
in any case we talked about the question
of
where are the places where there's some
natural experiment that has been
natural experiments a term of art but
where nature has
delivered you an experiment that you
didn't set up like an aircraft carrier
in which you've got an outbreak and
you've got a population that's separated
from the world but
you know it has the disease spreading
and how do you make use of these things
and how stupid are we that we are
doing foolish things like allowing such
a ship to dock without being very
careful to
you know to keep the population separate
so that we can track
this limited group and this is more this
is more of the same we have all kinds of
opportunities
and we are missing the uh
the value that would come from just
simply just figuring out where we are by
using the obvious
means at our disposal yep
next question might it also be that
sexual tension between mentors and
mentees causes the mentorship to be more
effective
this could be tested by looking at
same-sex attracted pairs
so let me start the the final thing this
could be tested by looking at same-sex
attracted pairs
is interesting and um
i think you know i think that that would
be the right
the right test of this the hypothesis
i doubt i think there can be
sexual tension between mentors and
mentees and everyone knows of these
stories of people who
held it together until the person
graduated and it turns out they were in
love the whole time and
they lived their lives happily ever
after and of course there are a lot of
those
stories that don't end nearly so well i
think that must be a
majority um
[Music]
my sense both anecdotally
and just just more broadly
is that the last thing that you want
um and the last thing that any of my
female friends in graduate school or
anywhere else ever wanted was any
threat or prospect of any kind of sexual
tension at all
um between us and you know either a
mentor or frankly
or you know an advisee you know once we
once i became a professor myself like
you just you just do not want that to be
there and that's not to say that there
that there isn't sometimes some you know
something that is like a recognition
that like okay you know
you're male i'm female and we're both
straight but
you know something that is fleeting and
gone is quite different from the idea of
oh there's this thing that we're both
sort of not looking at
and it's upping our game
i would predict the opposite yeah i
would think it would it would
slow down the game that's not that sort
of thing you would have three categories
here
yeah you would have categories in which
the
mentor was attracted you would have
category in which the mentee was
attracted
and category in which both were
attracted and my guess
is yeah i hadn't even thought of this
right like usually it's going to be
unrequited on one end
right yeah so the thing is here's the
reason i strongly doubt it
um and i think actually will go in the
opposite direction is to the extent that
there's any reality
in the idea that there is you know male
wisdom about how to get [ __ ] done that
involves
um poking holes in your friends work so
that it gets better
it doesn't apply within a romantic
situation right the opposite applies
and so to the extent that such
attractions
exist i would guess that they compromise
that value if that's in fact what's
being measured but it would be it's you
know it's a it's a hypothesis that goes
in a different direction
so uh be well worth figuring out what
are these you know
what is the effect of all of these
things but i agree that same-sex
attracted pairs is the way to test that
hypothesis
yeah um and then this next question just
follows up on that one
um maybe the person asks wittgenstein
was homosexual
i don't know enough about consent to say
anything about that or does my russell
wittgenstein example suggest
more to student teacher relations than
the paper assumes
pace lenny bernstein and etymology of
learn
i think there's a lot in there but i
don't know enough about the context
to to know yeah okay i don't know either
i would have been okay i would have been
honored to have you as my professors i
am a conservative born in nicaragua
raised in venezuela adopted by this
great country
thank you indeed please chat about an
idea
monetize us immigration draw what is
going on
um please chat about an idea monetize
u.s immigration draw by creating digital
immigration currency
handout in worldwide ubi with preference
for us citizens exchange for citizenship
use passport info for civil resistance
generative foreign policy i so i this is
enough outside of my wheelhouse that i
think even if
this was if this person had a paragraph
to write it with all the words included
i don't it's not really anything that i
know how to say much about
but i'm having a hard time even quite
tracking the proposal
yeah i don't i can't make heads or tails
out of it okay
there are there are limits and we we
have in process
a uh a new way to ask questions that
will hopefully be available soon
which may allow for slightly more
characters for questions that warrant
them
okay next question is there an
evolutionary reason
for people being more individualistic or
going along with the mob
our lizard brain phrase the phrase our
lizard brain made me think of how fish
travel in schools and others not so much
and how that might apply to humans
oh yeah many
many uh evolutionary reasons and
i guess my answer to this would be
we don't talk enough about niches and we
haven't
we haven't broadened the concept to get
full usefulness out of it and this is an
extension of a principle
uh that i use for for lots of things
which is that there's often
something discovered in a field that's
very very important
and then it is hobbled by the fact that
it is forever associated with the field
in which it was first spotted
rather than broadened to its natural
scope so my favorite
example of this would be diminishing
returns which i would argue
is the most powerful concept in all of
complex adaptive systems
but because it's discovered in economics
people always think that you're using it
by analogy rather than
it's a fundamental property of the
complex uh
adaptive universe and so in any case
niche is like this niche is a concept
that exists in many many places
and the fact that niche is spelled out
first in
in biology is is hobbling and what i
would say is that there are social
niches that exist inside of human
societies and inside of human groups
and that we adapt based
on a developmental
feedback system where we sort of detect
that there's a niche we explore it if it
seems
rewarding it gets augmented and this has
a lot to do with why
there are uh birth order effects for
example right you're
then the home you were born into is not
the same home
that your elder siblings were born into
because they've altered what the
available niche space looks like
so yes there are going to be all kinds
of reasons that you might be
um more susceptible to mob mentality or
more likely to be an independent
heterodox
pain in the ass thinker or whatever and
they will have a lot to do
with what niches were open to you
when you were young and that you'd you
know the fact that a niche may have been
open doesn't mean anything if you didn't
discover it so
there's some intersection of what was
the total niche space
which part of it did you find and what
cascade of things did it result in
and my guess is if we had that map for
all of us we'd know an awful lot about
why our personalities end up the way
they do
terrific question i work for a large
public water utility in the role as a
safety officer
maintenance which can be deferred will
require workers to be in close proximity
should i inform the media to pressure my
general manager to delay
i have advised against it informed osha
etc do i have a duty greater than legal
and moral
if i go to the media this will pressure
my gm my general manager
i will probably lose my job what is your
advice
maintenance that can be deferred will
require workers to be in
close proximity now i think is the
implication yeah
and uh and your job is safety officer
um you know oh
we don't want to be offering you know
advice
um that that
is any you know it's it's no way legally
binding or any of this right like we're
we're not pretending to be in that role
from what little i've seen of this
question though
your job is safety officer and
the maintenance could be deferred in
your opinion
as safety officer which it is your job
to determine
the only thing that we can't know here
is what losing your job
will mean for your immediate and
long-term future
that said your job is safety officer and
the maintenance can be deferred and
people are going to be in close
proximity right now
during the peak pandemic presumably
i am assuming you're at the u.s i don't
know but in some place with
um a lot of a lot of infections
happening
um i would hope that you
feel free to go to the media
but it really depends on your personal
circumstance
yeah but i would also say it depends a
bit on what close proximity
means is close proximity so close that
if you
end up working with somebody who has
coveted you're very highly likely to get
it
or is it the kind of close proximity
that we are regularly
encountering in different things yeah i
mean i guess there there is definitely a
middle ground
like is is the work that need that
doesn't need to be done but is about to
be going to be done
is it such that each of the workers can
excuse themselves every 15 minutes for
five minutes
right that that the model that is
developing seems to suggest that
basically getting fully clean air
with some regularity um you know not
just having flow through in a space
but you're even if you're in a space
enclosed um
evacuating yourself from it with some
regularity and coming back to it can be
highly protective so you know is there
is there a way
to um mitigate the risk at some cost
presumably
to efficiency of getting the job done
yeah
or in this case
respirators it seems to me
that the problem with
masks and uh face shields and things
like that is that
if the environment fills up with
aerosolized
virus that it eventually overwhelms
these protections
and uh you you
breathe it in a way that you can get an
infection
but that there may be a higher level of
protection which would allow the work to
be done
and then frankly what i would do in your
shoes i think
is i would submit a report that said
here's the risk
here are the possible
mitigating uh remedies that could be
applied
here's the rank order of their
effectiveness
and then here is the possibility of
delaying the work
and i would i think i would deliver that
to my superiors and put the onus on them
and you know do you go to the media
that's a tough one i think i don't know
enough about the situation to even begin
to
to say whether that makes sense it
really depends on how much
uh you know what population of people
you're protecting from what level of
risk
yep something like that okay we're going
to answer a couple more here
before going to the questions from this
hour
this one is two different um
comments from the same person of such
totally different tenor that i thought
i'd just read them both
power couple right here america needs to
listen true leaders of our communities
okay thank you and then from the same
person
gender dysphoria is a result of misandry
also known as feminism
pay attention to who was causing the
division in our country dragons of chaos
so um i'm going to take issue with miss
andrey
also known as feminism um there is a lot
of
uh there there are there are people who
call themselves feminists now and
for decades now i've been privately to
you and sometimes to my students been
calling them faux feminists f-a-u-x
you have been calling i have been
calling them faux feminists um
who identify as being part of third and
fourth and
nth way of feminism um that yeah
it is about um it does have a strong
misandrist component for sure but that
is not inherently what feminism
is and um this is not the top of my list
to you know reclaim that word um but i
would it is one of the words that i
would like to reclaim
um feminism as as a word that doesn't
mean that so
um let's take out the really the kind of
it's not misogyny in this question it's
like this anti-feminism
in this question and say is the claim is
gender dysphoria is a result of
effectively third and fourth wave
feminists um
stigmatizing but i'm having a hard time
i mean really the argument could i've
seen the argument that
a lot of for instance the teenage girls
who
are transitioning many of whom then
detransition afterwards to you know
transition into becoming boys will say
things
like i just couldn't see how being a
girl was going to
feel good in society and so you know
they're responding to what they
see as sort of a pervasive misogyny now
i don't see that either i don't see a
pervasive misogyny in society and i
didn't when i was a
teenage girl i saw a lot of stuff that i
didn't like but i didn't see pervasive
misogyny
um so um there you know there are people
claiming rampant misogyny and rampant
misandry and i do
see that a lot of the you know the woke
culture
is very interested in demonizing all
that has had privilege in the past and
that includes men
um but if anything i think uh gender
dysphoria
to the degree that it's partially about
hating on some group uh it has been
about hating on women rather than men
because of the direction that we're
seeing so much of the gender dysphoria
happening now
yeah i mean i think you know
let's do this slightly differently um
we have a garbage notion
of maleness and femaleness that has
taken over and we're being told what we
are to think of each
and it all kind of sucks and it's not
surprising to find people who have
through no fault of their own landed in
one sex or the other
deciding this is no good i'm not all
that excited about this
maybe the solution is the other thing
right right so anyway
i think it's a i guess the question is
why
why is the questioner focused on one
side of this equation when in fact
it might be a predictable result of
garbagey um well so but it's but it's
also true and you just you may not know
this this statistic which i believe i
learned actually from abigail schreier
is which is that historically
uh trans people have been much more
um male to female yep and
uh right now the the just the
skyrocketing numbers
are specifically younger people with
very often with
almost no history or any history of
gender non-conformity
who are female to male right and so that
that change
um suggests a something that is you know
societal and
and such but also suggests a you know
running away from femaleness
right but um the
question here is focused on gender
dysphoria and if i'm not mistaken
a lot of the wave of female to male
transgenderism is actually not based
in gender dysphoria well they claim it
is well
no i mean a there's some claim of that
but i think there's an
awful lot of recognition and in fact
this whole
uh this whole terminology
around transmedicalism uh
and uh and all of this is about the
assertion that gender dysphoria is not
required
is not required but you but you hear so
i've just
you hear a lot of the girls talking
about sort of re creating
in their past that they were actually do
experience were experiencing gender
dysphoria
and then if they transition off and
saying yeah well actually maybe that
wasn't
maybe that wasn't the case at all yeah
but in any case
to the extent that gender dysphoria is
central to this question
yeah it is consistent with the idea that
miss andrew might be at the root of it
and certainly at this moment
all of the discussion about masculinity
being uh closely associated with
toxicity or being synonymous with it or
whatever
um fits yeah i mean it fits except
that's not that's not
the way that that's not the group that
is experiencing such a tremendous amount
of um
right so anyway i i i don't actually
think it does
fit given what the numbers say heather
you it so we're gonna go through three
more of these before moving to
this hour heather you had once mentioned
that you've been working on a sci-fi
story prior to the evergreen fiasco
where the planet goes through evolution
differently can you please tell us more
about it and if it would ever be made
um so i actually talked about this a
little bit again at the end of the
impact theory
uh episode that i just did how do you
pronounce this last name
do you know by bill you volume okay i
don't think you know
because you missed a letter um so um
you've now outed me i'm sorry i'm sorry
um
yeah i would when when our book
is is final um there may be another book
that i want to work on first but i do
i absolutely do hope to um
go back to it get into a forum that i am
um
excited to share it and then try to get
it published so i did i wrote the
science fiction novel i was on
sabbatical and
literally finished the second draft the
day the riots broke out at evergreen
um and so have this complete draft that
i'm excited about
and just just to correct one little
thing in the question it is about the
search
for evolution of consciousness on other
planets
and so it has it it follows uh some
people some humans from earth who go to
a planet
uh that they have reason to think given
the research program they're part of
might have not only life but conscious
life on it and what happens there
that's tremendously fun to uh to both
figure out what the planet would be like
from a physics perspective and therefore
what kinds of life might have evolved
there so my little
my tagline to myself that i was
imagining saying to potential agents was
um most good science fiction gets the
physics right but doesn't
necessarily get the biology right and
i'm aiming to do both
so um i'm i'm pretty pretty pleased with
that story but
uh but it's going to be at least a
little while before it sees the light of
day
next question at what point do different
species that share a common ancestor
stop being able to interbreed
what exactly determines the cutoff point
for this
so there is none this is i mean this is
a question that we could both
just say there's none it's not that easy
and we could spend
hundreds of hours talking about do you
have something intermediate between
those two options
yeah i mean i would say there's
certainly
no there's no point right
lions and tigers can interbreed um they
never encounter each other they've been
separated a very very long time
well but i mean there is a point because
lions and sea urchins can't interbreed
no but there's no but the point is many
things that are separated a lot less
than lions and tigers can't interbreed
and so the point is there is no point
it is arbitrary when this kicks in um
i would say the thing that is most
likely to make it kick
in is a change in chromosome number the
changing chromosome number is very hard
to get past
and uh so anyway that's not an absolute
as far as i know it's going to depend on
what's on which chromosomes but
i suspect that there that it often
happens without a change in either
ploidy or chromosome number
that the inability to interbreed and you
know we in biology talk about
um pre and post zygotic isolation
you know to creatures that can't
recognize each other as
potential partners but could breed if
their gametes came into contact
are separated in a different way but
it's a very one of them's become diurnal
and one of them's nocturnal so they just
never meet that sort of thing
right or don't recognize each other as a
potential mate like
does not compute right that um so
anyway all of these things are in play
but if you're looking for a rule as if
biology was a machine and there was a
an instruction about you know
interbreeding
it ain't there because it's very
different in in different clades
okay um could arces could a society
breed out sexuality from the human
species
no is the answer to that what would that
even mean
that we would be asexual but how do you
breed it out
well the answer is no oh okay
zach there i don't see a line here where
do i start do you know
um actually here we go i think it's here
are there any unambiguous videos of sex
typical behavior experiments from babies
or animals
you'd show to those who eschew the
notion of sex differences
um i don't know i don't i don't keep
track of that with regard to videos
um there's definitely there's solid
research on babies um where male babies
are more likely to
focus their attention for longer on
things and girl babies are more likely
to focus their attention for longer on
faces
um so is this about
human babies i mean animals is the
person looking
for examples of sex differences in baby
animals that would allow people to
understand
that no i don't think it's baby it's
babies or other animals
oh this is the idea true or other
animals yeah and i mean i think
really like any nature video yeah like
anything that attenborough has voiced
over
practically shows sex differences i mean
just look at bauer birds
or moose or anything anything yeah you
know
not a banana slug okay you make things
in which the differences are small
even you know monogamous creatures
gibbons for example yeah
have substantial differences yeah and
also you know look to
you know long-term pair-bonded
monogamous
organisms like like gibbons like swans
and
and yes still sea sex differences even
though they look alike they sound alike
but they don't look entirely like they
don't sound entirely alike so
um you know with regard to animals just
about you know anything
and then there's solid research out
there with regard to babies i don't know
if the videos are out there
um and there's tremendous cross-cultural
evidence as well
from you know pre-industrial cultures
that there are differences
and that it's not a weird you know
western educated industrial
rich democratic society construct it's
just not
just not okay why
next question are asians so flexible
this is going to be about physical
flexibility must women with thin
hips be flexible to give birth are men
flexible as a consequence of female
evolution
why do asians have thin hips are hip
width and flexibility correlated in all
humans
so this i happen to know is from someone
who
um herself is asian i'm just going to
say that lest people get
furious with us for answering this
question
um i don't it
never occurred to me that asians were
particularly flexible
um so i'm going to take that should we
take that as a
as a as a given here if
the assumption of the question is
accurate yeah then is that
so it's fascinating as always right um
is there a correlation between
um flexibility and thin hips
the questioner hypothesizes
um that thin hips and women
will make it more difficult to give
birth and that flexibility would
be a basically an adaptive response to
that difficulty
i think it's a fascinating hypothesis
that never occurred to me before
i think it's likely and i don't know how
i mean you could definitely find the
correlation find out if it's true or not
um i don't know if it's true across
other populations
right then hips and flexibility um but
then how even if if you found that to be
true
across say you look at eight distinct
enough populations of humans and you
find that there is
um the thinner the hips the more
flexible the
the people in general how would you
if that were true then test the
hypothesis that
the flexibility came after the hip width
uh and was about uh ease of giving birth
i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure i'm not
sure either
but um yeah it's worth thinking about
but i don't i don't have it offhand all
right
what do you folks think about the
injection of identity politics into the
environmental movement
we regularly discuss this at
greenrootpodcast.net
i don't know agreementpodcast.net um i
will look into it
i'm i'm excited at the idea that there
is a
ongoing discussion about identity
politics about the problem of identity
politics
in the environmental movement because
that's that's what it is it's just it's
getting in the way of so many important
things
and you know we saw this just a little
bit i mean i i
i it's a problem is the short answer but
i remember um in advance of our study
abroad trip
in 2017 where we were doing a year-long
program
and so we had all of our students in 20
fall of 2016 who we were getting to know
and just little glimmers from a couple
students
um who were in this program about you
know evolution tropical biology and all
behavior and statistics and all of these
things and you know going to the amazon
galapagos and
and such um you'd get occasional offhand
comments
like um you can't focus on the
environment until you solve problems of
social justice
and you know that this was never i
remember two of these and it never
happened in class
but it was sort of offhand comments on
field trips before we were
um abroad um over dinner or something
and um and i i engaged
them and i think i think you overheard
one or two of these as well
and it turns out to have been just this
it was just a talking point
right there was there was no real
conviction or investigation behind
these things and frankly in both cases
the students were surprised to
experience any pushback at all
because they'd become accustomed to
being able to say this um
in you know among their among their
people
uh among their you know activist groups
or whatever they were
uh and not have any pushback and so for
me to say yeah i don't
i don't i don't see how you could make
that claim and at the very least
uh we have different positions that uh
we will be fighting for
and saying that no one can fight for
anything until we solve this other thing
is going to mean a lot of a lot fewer
people are fighting the good fight
yeah in fact it's the opposite of true
um and
it is let's put it this way it is a
strategic claim
and it is either hostage taking where
the idea is we won't let you solve your
environmental problem unless we solve
this other thing first so you better get
on board with this other thing
first or it is an attempt
at coalition formation but
the problem is first of all we are
arriving at a point in history where we
have a dire
ecological problem if it was true
that the um social problems that we have
were intractable
but the environmental problem was
solvable and needed to be solved you
would have to solve it and if it took us
another hundred years
of major human social injustice
where we had fixed the planet so that we
could continue to live here
that would be frankly a small price to
pay the fact that the
we have an existential threat that comes
from the unsustainability of the way we
live
on the earth whereas there's a justice
concern which clearly
we can persist even in a state of
injustice so these things are not even
of the same magnitude with respect to
their import but more importantly
um the fact is
any bigotry at all is
bad for functionality
right to the extent that you have biases
at all that interfere with your ability
to find
the best possible person to do the job
your bigotry will make you less
competitive and so to the extent
that there is a job to be done with
respect to solving our
environmental problems we want those
with the most
powerful arguments and the deepest
insight about it to be
leading the charge and to the extent
that you want to
correct social justice social injustices
that you think exist
inside of that movement before it can
even move you're decreasing the chances
that we will fix the earth's problem and
you have no right to do it
so yeah it's a
hmm a nasty little connection that has
been drawn and really is not logical
yeah very much so given your interest in
the idea of evolutionary medicine have
you read nessie and williams book why we
get sick the new science of darwinian
medicine
if so what did you think of it yeah it's
terrific we've talked about it before
here
uh we cite it in our book uh that we are
finishing now and it just it needs an
update it was what
93 i think something like that 93 90 mid
90s
it's absolutely fabulous i don't think
it's been a while since i've gone back
and read it cover to cover but i don't
think
anything in it has been any
big claims are demonstrably wrong
but there's a lot more that we know like
this was before anyone was talking about
for instance epigenetics things like
that
right so it's um it's dated in that
it is it doesn't say as much as it could
but it was a much needed first foray
into a field that unfortunately has
almost nothing as important as it
to follow it yeah it's a very important
founding book for the field actually we
were i mean we were lucky to
randy nessie was in our milieu at
michigan we were in seminars with him
and such
yeah he was like no he was not on your
commitment he's not but i took his uh
seminar on the book after it had come
out so anyway that was that was good we
also knew george williams
uh who died not long after um but in any
case yes it's very important we do need
a
2.0 version of that book or a much
larger series of books that deal with
the full breadth of the problem
but yeah it's the right idea absolutely
heather i suspect brett will disagree
with it but i would love to hear your
evaluation of rand's introduction to
objectivist epistemology
be well so this is going to be anarand
and anne i never know exactly how to
pronounce it with ein i don't think
that's too
germanic um anyway i you know
i read a little i didn't read that but i
read either
i didn't finish it i read either part of
atlas shrugged or or
one of the other tomes when i was in
high school or college and i
honestly just couldn't get very far with
it and have
tried to delve a little bit but um i
don't i just
i don't quite buy it and there's not
much more i can say
about this because i haven't read this
particular thing
yep yeah um you're correct i will
disagree with it but i will say
uh prototype yeah it's a it's it's
foolish to try
to implement this thinking or to think
of it as very high quality because it
isn't
but um yeah she was the first does it
appear down
a road that we might need to travel yes
and you know
i would say um the
objectivist philosophy has a piece of
the truth
i would say uh utilitarianism has a
piece of the truth
both of these things are wrong but um
fixing
i'd love to pursue with you how
utilitarianism is wrong maybe not now
given that work oh
because slavery is bad things like that
um you know it's just if you apply it
oh yeah right um okay
yeah but but the point is okay can you
fix it once you spot
that hazard and you know slavery just
stands in for everything else that it
will do
incorrectly um but once you spot that
can you fix it so that you accomplish
the thing that it thinks it's doing
without the hazard of what ultimately
happens if you just implement it too
directly
good without introducing so many
epicycles that it resembles its origin
story not at all and
why are you calling it the same thing
right or you know it takes you to the
place you've got to go to figure out
what you're really trying to do
so maybe it doesn't look like it's right
but it's not still the same thing yeah
do you retain anything in your waking
life conscious from listening to
something in your sleep
subconscious regularly i think this is
asking a
personal question to each of us as
opposed to whether people can because i
think you know people
people can uh you know i make a point of
not listening to things in my sleep
you know i i like dark and quiet for
sleep and so
no because i haven't i haven't tried
um so i have one violation of that i
also don't
want to be listing stuff as i sleep the
one and
geez it's been so long it seems but you
know we were traveling a ton
right flying all over the place giving
talks and stuff like this
it was fun it was fun but the plane
rides weren't necessarily fun no they're
not
and you know a lot of them a short trip
it was red eyes and so i would
very frequently put on my headphones and
try to sleep
with music or with audio with like or no
not music
but with music only i wouldn't it
wouldn't work with with spoken word
audible or something yeah
yeah um and so did i retain anything
well here
here's the story you're looking for but
hold on you were never listening to
music you'd never heard before
correct well no that's not true okay um
i'd be listening in general to pandora
which in general would be songs that i
had heard before but every so often it
throws you something you've never heard
okay um okay so i don't know what effect
it has but here's the
here's the thing first of all i think we
we are all quite different in this
regard and i don't know how many
categories we fit into
but back when i was a tyke when i was in
college
um i that's funny this story has a lot
of tendrils but
um i was in this terrible biology course
the intro biology course and i didn't
really [ __ ] need it because i had
already studied a lot of biology and was
pretty deeply encompassed in it and so
i was like in danger of failing this
course because
it was like it was the it was the weed
out course designed to get rid of all
the people who thought they were going
to be doctors
um and i didn't need to be weeded out
because i was going to be a doctor and
this course was not interesting was
taught by
robert rickliffs oh yeah so this is a
pen no
yeah a pen and actually at some point i
went up and i was like i need
dr rickless i need you to sign me out of
this course i need you to free me from
it because we were past the drop date
but i needed to get out
and he asked me why do you want out and
i was like it's killing me i
love biology and this is terrible and he
was like oh yeah you definitely need out
and he signed
uh on the dotted line but anyway before
that happened um
i would fall asleep in this course it
was so deadly bad
right and i noticed the pattern
as i was sitting there trying to stay
awake
and you know i was just it just was so
soperific that my i would close my
eyelids and i think okay that's all
right i can close them and i can listen
right and then there was a point before
actual sleep set in
but the sequence was okay eyelids close
and then i'm listening and then the
sound cuts out right and the
the room goes silent and that was like
the moment you know 15 seconds before
sleep would set in
so anyway what i know is that for me
my auditory cortex cuts off input
from my ears presumably because i'm
pretty auditory
and it's borrowing that resource for
dream stuff
um and so anyway oh that's interesting
right so uh that's that's very
interesting i suspect that you and i are
very different in this regard
to being so much more auditory in me
being so much more visual and that um
actually i am i am more sensitive
to auditory disturbances in my sleep
environment than i think you are and
this would
this would fit with that right and it
also fits with the fact
that if i am doing
something thought wise if i seem to be
doing nothing but i'm
deeply engaged in thought i'm doing it
auditorily
right so my ears are off i've noticed
yeah i know you have
completely maddening right but i mean
it's like literally it's not
like oh i'm not tuned into that channel
it's like no actually there's a
there's a cutoff and you know that that
gate has been flipped yeah no man this
people will imagine this is like oh this
is just what you know men and women do
i've been married for a while like no
no like i'm sure there's some of that
but but there is it is a different mode
you're like i wow you didn't hear those
last three things
and it's true that sometimes you can
give a resp
you can give a response even from within
your state
but it does it has a different it has a
different tone i feel like in retrospect
i kind of be like right you just weren't
you you just weren't even in the room
right your body was here
but here's the other thing is if you do
get my attention
right i've been lost and thought my mind
has been doing stuff in an auditory way
and my ears have been
off and you trigger me to hear
there's like a buffer of five ten
seconds worth of
what has been said that i can actually
yeah yeah totally at which point it
uh would sometimes anyway feel to be
like well then you were just ignoring me
because you were listening exactly
well i'm glad we've had this little talk
because
yeah sooner or later this was going to
result in in divorce if we hadn't
discussed this but no this is absolutely
real yeah no i
i know i mean we have we have had this
conversation a little bit
yeah okay a couple more
one working hypothesis mask wearing by
both sides
distancing minimal interaction will
result in lower exposure and therefore
less severe
non-obvious effects versus deaths uh
infection resulting in a higher positive
ve
test rate but negative ve mortality
implications question mark what's pos
what's what does that positive ve mean
you know positive v
e and negative v i feel like that's a
known thing that i just don't recognize
do you know zach i'm still having
trouble parsing this question
working hypothesis mask wearing on both
sides both people
distancing with minimal interaction
will result in lower exposure
so far so good and therefore less severe
infection
possible that fits with uh stuff that we
talked about a lot in the early live
streams it's density dependent
and it's density dependent both in terms
of are you likely to get it and if you
do get it how severe is it likely to be
um but i don't so i think
this hypothesis that we've proposed i
think i don't know
um i don't know what the ve test rate is
yeah so i'm not sure what more to say
about this except that i think
i think what you've described is pretty
accurate and the dog is telling us we've
been here for too
long long too long it's time to pay
attention to the dog
yes um
you find anything zach okay
yeah that's fine um
i think this is an option hi
live in china debt free all debt
absolved
able to practice unfettered in your
field in a reverse operation paperclip
or statewoke us
oh god um yeah that's a rough one
uh reverse operation paperclip yeah
boy yeah i don't
[Laughter]
um i don't know can we go to the bahamas
instead
yeah um yeah yeah
um okay let me let me find
state woke us that doesn't sound like
fun but
you know the problem is the problem is
you've set up a
lose-lose situation that
i'm going to try to forget you ever
mentioned as soon as the broadcast is
over
yeah um okay we're going to finish on
this question
hi yeah um did you know that the earth
is flat
and dinosaurs never existed yes
that didn't result in much okay
yes the earth is the earth is both
bumpy and also round and dinosaurs
did exist and they still do so
i'm not really sure where you're coming
from oh okay we're going to finish here
this is the last question question
just came in and we'll return to a few
of these next time
post-lockdown study in wuhan china shows
there were no infections from
asymptomatic people
published in nature magazine are masks
and lockdowns pointless to people with
no symptoms if it is true
so i think this is a i think this is a
reference to
a paper that i saw and didn't get to
spend much time with
um but the description
is is very much like this i wasn't sure
that it was
no it was china um that um they did such
a complete track and trace that they
found that asymptomatic people
um who were nonetheless positive were
not
um not
giving the giving the transmitting the
virus yeah but but
but i believe that what they could not
see with this study and again i'd have
to spend more time with it
is that the highly infectious period for
people who
do end up being quite sick from it is
very early in the infection
and when those people who will become
symptomatic
are still asymptomatic and those people
who are
uh temporally asymptomatic but will
become symptomatic or not included
in this list of asymptomatic people so
what we have is two different kinds of
asymptomatic
and at any moment that you are
asymptomatic you don't know
if you know maybe you're just not
infected maybe you're asymptomatic and
you always will be
and um you're one of these people who
gets it and it seems to mean very little
hopefully there aren't long-term effects
who knows
and maybe you're one of these people who
is asymptomatic at the moment and will
become
highly very sick and in which case your
asymptomatic
thing right now is probably correlated
with high infection right
so i mean that from if i'm if i'm
thinking about the same paper i have to
spend more time with the paper
that's a really important distinction
that is being missed in the assessment
of this study that asymptomatic
is not one thing and only one kind of
asymptomatic is
what this paper is talking about yeah
this is what i was going to
guess here and i think at least in some
of the virology community i've seen
this point made about pre-symptomatic
versus
asymptomatic right but it looks you know
when you don't know which it is you're
looking at all
you you might use that term asymptomatic
as an umbrella term
with asymptomatic and pre-symptomatic as
terms of art
but one of the term of art terms of art
and when the umbrella and the umbrella
term are the same and that just makes
communication nearly impossible
right but from the point of view of this
question the answer is then masks are
useful even in the case of people who
don't have symptoms because some of them
are pre-symptomatic and likely to be
infectious before
they know they're sick right um but you
know
good treat really good testing and
really widespread testing and really
rapid testing
would solve this problem right we'd be
able to get there
really good testing being key yes
because cruddy testing
i'm beginning to be concerned about
credit testing being widespread and
creating a whole different problem
no you're not you and i were both
concerned about that in april
i think we may have a new version of the
problem but anyway we'll uh
we'll return there later okay all right
i think we will stop there today it's
been a while we've been on for a while
so um join our patreons i'll be um
like i said opening up that window for
um
questions to be that we will be
answering in our q a not tomorrow but
next sunday
shortly on my patreon look at the clips
channel
check out various things check out
various things
and um have a fantastic thanksgiving and
yes not american it doesn't matter it's
a perfectly
excellent idea to have a holiday based
on thankfulness
and as much as this has been a really
truly sucky year
in many different ways we have a lot to
be grateful for
and uh we'll get through it and if if
you can
if you can enjoy good food and be aware
of the people
whom you love and who love you even if
you can't be with them that is a
blessing
yep all right be well everyone see you
next time